what's going on guys today we're going
to explain the full backstory of
yuno who is astor's main rival in black
clover
and a guy who can seemingly do no wrong
okay well
most of the time this character has
really interested me
ever since i began this series because i
was always kind of confused as to how
this poor orphan
was just so good at magic even more so
than nobles and royalty
as the manga progresses we finally did
get some answers as to why he's so
talented
and so this video will cover those
tragic events and you know his whole
backstory
up until we first meet him in the anime
if you'd like me to do more black clover
videos then be sure to drop a like
and let me know any topics that you
think are worth covering in the future
okay so yuno was originally born inside
the spade kingdom
which is the largest and currently the
strongest
of the four main countries in black
clover his family was known as house
grim burial
who ruled over the country peacefully
and for most people
life was good with the exception of the
spade kingdom's
cold climate in the manga we get one
look at yuno's mother whose name was
lady seal
but we don't get a solid look at his dad
however it is known that his name
was lord loyce when yuno was still a
baby
someone entered the dangerous magic
region that exists between the kingdoms
and acquired this magic stone which was
then given to the young prince
for those of you who've watched the
anime you'll know the power and
importance of this stone
and so it was pretty crazy that it was
just found seemingly lying in the
dangerous magic region and yeah yunus
just had it since day one
sometime after this the king of the
spade kingdom was killed
by dante zagratis who was an unsatisfied
member of the spay kingdom military
and he had gained incredible power by
making a deal
with the devil known as lucifer oh
actually i mean lucifero
together with his siblings xenon and
vanica they were collectively known as
the dark triad
and began to eliminate all the different
members of the royal family
with their devil magic making them
almost impossible to defeat
that being said though since yuno's
birth there was a guy called ralph
who was given the responsibility of
protecting him rael's family had served
yuna's family
for generations and his father was
captain of the spake kingdom's magic
defense force
as the dark triad was killing off all
the different royals ralph's father took
uno
and fled into the strong magic region
what was especially terrifying about
this moment
was that ralph senior and yuno were just
meters away from being killed by xenon
who to me is the most terrifying member
of the dark triad
if it wasn't for these two guys right
here who intervened
it's highly likely that yuno never would
have survived
like i alluded to earlier the strong
magic region itself
is incredibly dangerous so for ralph's
dad to successfully travel across it
with a baby in hand
super super impressive stuff once they
made it to the edge of the clover
kingdom
ralph senior used the last of his
strength to leave yuno outside this
church
in hajj village alongside his magic
stone
this village is a poor area located in
the forsaken realm of the clover kingdom
and most people there have very little
magic power and
few opportunities beyond farming on that
same day
it just so happened that astor was also
abandoned outside the church
directly next to the young spake kingdom
prince
and in the anime their names were
written in similar writing
which has many many implications i mean
to me it makes it look like they were
brought by the same person
but as you can see ralph was only
carrying one uh one child
so i don't know exactly how aster ended
up there yet
but i'm sure we will find out soon
enough the two of them grew up together
as brothers
and shared the same birthday which from
their perspective their birthday is the
day that they were found
at the church during their childhood
yoona was incredibly timid
and he would just cry at minor
inconveniences and was genuinely fearful
of the world around him
that said his attitude first began to
change when he heard the story
of the first wizard king which if you've
watched black clover you've probably
seen that story
at least a hundred times i know i have
youno was both intrigued by the story
and also by astor's crazy declaration to
become the next wizard king
at this time hajj village had never had
one of its residents become a magic
knight so to claim to become the wizard
king who you know commands all the magic
knight squads that's a pretty
bold thing to say many months later hajj
village was running out of food and yuno
was given the sole responsibility
to deliver a letter to a neighboring
village asking for supplies
and after successfully delivering the
letter he was attacked by a drunk guy on
the way back
who wanted to steal and then sell his
magic stone
whilst yuno attempted to get it back he
was pretty much powerless against this
grown man
and yeah he was if if no one had
intervened he likely would have lost
the magic stone lucky for him though
astor realized that yuno had been gone
for quite a while
and so he went to kind of investigate
and once he showed up
he managed to get the stone back just
through sheer persistence
in the process astor got pretty beaten
up but he reaffirmed his desire to
become the wizard king
so that poor people in the forsaken
realm would never have to worry about
things like food or money ever again
and also just to prove to people that
anybody can become the wizard king if
they put the work in
this moment is what inspired you spirit
and gave him the resolve to try and
become the next wizard king himself
and also gave him the resolve to never
cry again which i don't know if that's
healthy but you know it's what he wanted
to do
because they both now had the same goal
and obviously only one of them can be
the wizard king
from that point forward they became
official rivals i guess
the manga shows us how a young youno
spent tons of time practicing with his
win magic
whilst also secretly keeping tabs on
astor's progress
as a consequence of this rivalry unit's
personality
drastically changed over the years from
a timid crybaby
to a person who's unfazed by most things
and just has supreme confidence that he
can overcome
anything and anyone his level of skill
is equal to that of royalty
if not greater but as we know now you
know he does come from spade kingdom
royalty so it all makes sense
but with that said that was the full
backstory
of you know grim burial i hope i'm
hoping i'm saying that last name right
because i've never actually said it out
loud until this video
but yeah that was his backstory if
you've not seen black clover and you're
kind of interested in this character
then i would definitely recommend
picking up the series either the manga
or the anime
and you can learn all about him you know
this was just explaining what happened
before
we meet him in the anime so if you want
to know everything else then check it
out i would recommend it
let me know down below which topics you
might like to see me cover from black
clover
and until the next one peace out